je suivais dingue de toi tous ensemble
ils chantent ils dansent ils sont sexy
qu lui-même quantique rock dans un
sandwich que sont les boys boys boys
boys comme on dit entre 1996 et 2000
ils ont squatté des sommet du hit-parade
viage g squad tube if lui trois groupes
entre pop et euro dance
le boys band ans la française portée par
une communauté de fans parfois
nv vous et je suis prête à faire 28
heures de train de partir des côtes
d'armor jusqu'à nice
nos portées devant appartement d'un des
chanteurs dalo émission télé d'alors
dédicaces et surmonta d'hystérique
500000 exemplaires vendus pour l'album
écrit du premier album d'alliages sorti
en 1997 celui dans lequel on pouvait
entendre avec moi mais qu'est ce qui
plaît tant dans les boys band c'est une
sorte de réussite pour les jeunes
on voit que l'on peut être jeune et
réussir quand même il chante bien
[Musique]
à l'exception des to be free les boys
berne sont de pur produit marketing
léger squad par exemple tout est parti
d'un casting 60 candidats quatre garçons
choisi avant tout pour ce que la nature
leur a donné les textes ont été écrits
en amont il n'y a plus qu'à leur
apprendre à chanter
mon moment
leur apprendre à danser et à s'habiller
voilà la recette trouvée par l'industrie
de la musique des budgets dans un groupe
de rock c'était pour payer les studios
de répète ou je ne sais quoi
lesté de support tournée là c'est plutôt
des cours de chorégraphie et les gardes
du corps bois et des cours de chant
d'accord en france les années 2000 ont
signé l'arrêt des boys band
ils n'ont pas connu la longévité de
certains concurrents américains
aujourd'hui encore en activité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]